leute ich bin gespannt wie es bereits im
titel eingeblendet das heute gewicht
etwas mit eine kleine woche dazu tun und
zwar mit diesem kleinen roboter haben
das ist die cosmo als erben haben
schläge kauft weil einige von euch
meinen henker in deinen letzten video
wurde dieser instagram gadgets getestet
hat ich drück nicht nennen jemand hat
ihm unterliefen video meinung sehr viele
von euch wenn du kannst noch eine übung
laufe nicht viel größeren roth habe und
zwar diesen die cosmo der soll nun
heftig gut sein deswegen habe ich mit
den x gekauft der lädt hier unten gerade
[Musik]
dort noch ein bisschen 2000 jahre später
leute wenn wir jetzt einige jahre
gewartet
der kopf muss auf jeden fall fertig
aufgeladen dass ich jetzt einfach mal
auf weiter und setzte kosten auf einen
sauberen und nicht mit anderen
gegenständen bedeckten tisch
also ich klicke einfach auf staaten
france mobil zum leben erweckt wird hier
schon was nicht dass der jetzt denke ich
wäre sein besitzer weil er aufgebracht
ist mich als erstes gesehen hat und
kostenlos ein ganz besonderer roboter
der von seinem besitzer gegen gepflegt
werden will
hier steht man soll jetzt einen tube
verkäufen aufstellen
ich glaube der untersuchte diesem cube
oder ein paar sekunden später das hat er
nicht gesagt ob jetzt
[Applaus]
sehr wohl nur wenig
ja bis jetzt seine mission kleiner man
mir fehlt jetzt kosmos ich gerne
kennenlernen auf kennenlernen er mich
gewehrt von meinen namen ein paar soll
man hier machen weiter die schau
geradeaus in die richtung von kochen und
bewege dich nicht freuen sich total
gesehen gemeinsame kleine kamera bei
geld richtig süß kann jetzt einfach mal
auch mal persönlich
da gebe ich jetzt einfach mal david
einzige auch weiter und jetzt schaut er
damit an das menü der jetzt aus also
mitspielen und tricks fühlt sich seine
spiel anzeige mit tricks können wir uns
bei wir machen einfach mal kurzen trick
also ich gehe jetzt haben wir auf jubel
und ok ich glaube er hat den klub
gefunden
[Musik]
jetzt steht die duh hat die spiele
anzeige von cosmo gefüllt und erhält
dafür eine bonus kiste das heißt leute
mit kisten und da sind jetzt sachen drin
oder was 106 du hast du weißt verdient
also ich hab jetzt weil sie so schwarz
bekommen und ich habe einen neutrik
freigeschaltet fauststoß vorher kann
graf kopf und ich werden jetzt mal der
fisch band machen dass alles klappt man
so viele wieder den rhythmus noch
freischalten
was wollen wir erst mal hören
[Musik]
im alter wird steht auch das kochen eine
sprachausgabe hat derzeit koch bereitet
sich davor zu spielen
wir können einen begriff hierhin
schneidet den kurs modern sagt
[Applaus]
ach der weigert sich weil ich scheiße
geschrieben habe was brennt kommt
dürften nur wenige minuten später war
beleidigend
[Gelächter]
ich habe geschrieben david stinkt nach
scheitern dann hab ich geschrieben david
stinkt nach kacke dann habe ich
geschrieben das stinkt wie ein stinktier
das hat er alles nicht angenommen also
es gibt hier wirklich ganz ganz viele
verschiedene sachen die wir machen
können wir haben es ja nur kennenlernen
sprachausgaben und ein bisschen tricks
macht wird sagen einen weiteren trick
machen wir noch mal eben diesen trick
lernt cosmo zwei chips übereinander zu
stapeln
[Musik]
mein kopf muss so dumm wer gut so wenn
du jetzt geradeaus fährt es könnte sein
dass es nicht hält ja genau noch ein
bisschen davor noch einmal vorkomme vor
den kopf nein nein
[Musik]
wie lange braucht genau in den winkel da
drauf
[Musik]
damit geriete auch okay jetzt braucht er
den staffeln anscheinend auch wieder ab
und setzt den würfel hier daneben
irgendwohin kassen das hat überhaupt
keinen sinn ergeben als nächstes mache
ich jetzt mal starten umwerfen und halt
schauen
ein zerstörer modus glaube das war
bruder jakobus sehr gut neuer kosmos
schluckauf steht hier gerade okay okay
hier steht das man kochen auf den kopf
stellen soll und dann gibt es halt
direkt gegen seinen willen aber hat mich
befreit
okay noch schmucker kosmos geht wieder
gut wir haben jetzt hier noch einige
andere sachen die wir machen können wie
beispielsweise ein erkundungs modus
spiele also wir haben auch
beispielsweise hier wir haben so auch
noch ein paar minispiele und so was wir
machen können
ich kann mit dem handy cosmo lenken
[Musik]
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus ich kann
einfach mal so drehen dann wäre ich
schon cosmo dreht sich jetzt zu mir
rüber werden wird jetzt mensch auch er
doch luca erkannt jetzt habe ich hier
quasi den kopf von ebenso ein bisschen
hoch runter machen und ich kann auch
seine liebe armbewegung besser so hoch
machen oder dem leben wieder runter
machen und damit kam ich konnte mir
fordert zurückfahren einmal schauen ob
er erkennt dass hier andere wir vorher
finger eingeklemmt dass ich immer noch
eine gesichtserkennung habe ich habe
nicht mal auf brauch ist gedrückt und er
wollte gerade einfach so eine an der
stelle mich dass heute wieder das
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe mir diesen anti cosmo
einfach gekauft weil ich mir dachte hey
damit kann ich locker neuestes video
machen nicht mehr der kleine erkennt der
dich noch mal ich finde sowas megageil
mit solchen robotern irgendwelchen
videos zu machen und ich feiere das auch
häufig dieses kleine anti cosmo
dunkerque ist noch ganz viele andere
sachen wie beispielsweise portal
ergreifen eines spieles juni und ritter
noch gar nicht mehr
cosmo möchte spiele nicht einfach mal
auf nein freunde weißer traurig die arme
obwohl dieser doppel männer gibt ist
hier gefallen hat und ihr bock drauf
habe dass ich einen zweiten teil mit
diesem kleinen roboter mal hochladen
lassen ein leitbild 40.000 live
in ein zwei wochen der zweite teil
kommen wo wir mit den spielen werden wir
werden das ding twin gewährten es
füttern wenn ihr euch mit diesem anti
kosten roboter auskennen oder ihr selber
so ein ding hat er dann schreibt mir
gerne kommentar dieses video mit
irgendwelchen tipps oder dingen die wir
vielleicht damit noch machen können dann
machen wir das im nächsten video nochmal
meine es gibt ja auch noch voll für die
freizuschalten ja jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]
ein